logan allen out there on the mound
making his sixth start this year
he's got time to
set everything straight they could use a
nice start grossman three hits in his
last 39 at bats but he draws a lead off
walk
jonathan scope three for eight in the
series
ground ball could be two let's see that
is jag steps on the back or clement
rather stepping on the bag and a good
buggy whip throw over to first to
complete the double play in the 2-2
ground ball routine play for you chang
and that'll do it for the tigers here in
the first and the pitcher for the tigers
and game two will be willie peralta he's
making his fourth appearance in his
third start his last
timeout was on saturday pitching that
double header versus houston received no
decision
caught by jamer candelario
one two to ahmed rosario
a chopper to shore zach short
steady as she goes to away
rosario sends one to right field
yes cameron's got plenty of room and
that's a 14 pitch start for willie
peralta miguel cabrera picked up an rbi
in game one on a sacrifice fly
and he starts this game off with another
softly served single into right field
well he's swinging it well today
2-0 pitch bloop to right center field
bradley zimmer with a dynamite play
throwing back to first but miguel gets
back there
in time to avoid being doubled off well
that's a dynamite jump and a great
sliding catch by zimmer well he had one
in game one but he fell short and
had a divot but this one he's able to
get to
and get a body underneath
well good play by zimmer to retire
cameron 6 for 21 for zach short
including a home run here's the 2-2
and a bullet to left
that is caught by eddie rosario
miguel cabrera will score on the
sacrifice fly and detroit has the early
lead two away for willy castro
castro down the right field line that
ball is fair there you go a ground rule
double for willie castro and eric haas
scores the tigers second run here in the
second hit them where they ain't he got
a little spin the ball bounced up into
the stance gonna be a ground rule double
but
that plate's eric hawes
tried to hold up but he went around
logan allen strikes it up but the tigers
strike for two in the second and take
the early lead so one on two out and
bradley zimmer to the plate
smoke deep center hill is back it's over
his head it's off the wall takes a crazy
carom zimmer can fly he's off to the
races scoring his clement bradley into
third he'll hold him there they got the
relay in quickly it's a two-out rbi
triple for bradley zimmer who got his
first extra base hit of the year in game
one and he follows that up with a big
two out rbi triple here in game two that
one i mean hit the center field wall and
hit the corner out there and watch it
ricochet past hill and you're right i
started thinking about it inside the
parker when i saw that one but the
hustle of cameron coming over to get the
ball in certainly kept him in at third
base so he had a double in game one his
first extra base city gets a double here
drives in a run and makes it a two to
one game
and he does right there again strikes
him out his first punch out tonight for
willie peralta cleveland does get a run
it's 2-1 the tigers in front that'll
bring up eric haas who walked and scored
in the second
there it is there's a drive deep left
field that ball's gone
eric haas's first hit against his old
team is a solo bomb to put the tigers in
front three to one
he was waiting for that pitch
and you can almost sense in what he
did at the plate with the three takes
he's like if you throw me a fastball i'm
gonna crush it and he didn't miss it
that's the difference
is when you get that cookie what do you
do with it
and he just hammered it
that's power
442 feet away
eric haas's ninth homer of the season
the tigers back in front by two and
forced cleveland to their bullpen in the
fourth
popped him up this will get him out of
it ernie clement calling for it
inning over
tigers tack one on on the homer by haas
as they lead it three to one facing a
new tri pitcher it's nick witkin here in
the fifth
there's a ball up the middle and a
backhanded play by clementi tried to
flip it to rosario but
unable to complete the play and jonathan
scope has a leadoff single for detroit
here
in the fifth
line caught throwback to first double
play
nicely done by you change yeah it was
that sure was
that ball stayed up and it would have
been a double play anyway you look at it
if he if he doesn't catch it in the air
they're going to turn it with the short
hop because you see rosario's right
there
in that first base he got a little too
far off the bag
and that good throw comes back and gets
two away from miguel cabrera you get it
fly ball deep right field that ball is
gone
miguel cabrero the big fly number
494 in his career and the tigers open up
a three-run lead
well the big fella is heating up it's
good to see i don't know what it is
about playing in this ballpark
but progressive field is home for miguel
cabrera
and he shows it again in game two here
tonight
gets a fastball and we talked about how
he's starting to get to those
good for him
instep's derrick hill
up the middle that's a base hit
beautiful
haas
scores and so does zach short
a two-run single for derrick hill his
second and third rbis of the year 6-1
tigers
1-2
fly ball dropping and harold ramirez
can't come up with it
derrick hill scores
that'll be an rbi single from jonathan
scope and the tigers extend their lead
it's now 7-1 joe jimenez is now being
called upon to work the seventh his 21st
appearance
popped it up
shallow right center it's willy castro
who puts it away the tigers sweep this
double header from cleveland by scoring
16 runs overall and a balanced scoring
attack and a job well done